GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THINGS ARE MOVING FAST IN
AMERICAN POLITICS, BUT SEE IF
YOU CAN REMEMBER BACK FIVE
MONTHS TO LAST FALL.
AT THE TIME, ELIZABETH WARREN OF
MASSACHUSETTS WAS THE MOST
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
SHE HAD BIG LEADS IN BOTH IOWA
AND NEW HAMPSHIRE.
SHE HAD OVERTAKEN ESTABLISHMENT,
DESIGNATED FRONT-RUNNER
JOE BIDEN THE NATIONAL POLLING.
THE RACE LAST FALL WAS WARREN’S
TO LOSE.
AND LOSE IT, SHE DID,
SPECTACULARLY.
WARREN DIDN’T WIN A SINGLE
STATE.
IN FACT, SHE NEVER TOOK SECOND.
SHE GOT CREAMED IN
MASSACHUSETTS, WHERE SHE LIVES.
TODAY, FINALLY, WARREN DROPPED
OUT, HAVING SUCCEEDED ONLY IN
HUMILIATING HERSELF.
AS THE BABYLON BE LOOK PUT IT, W
RETURNS TO THE TRIBE IN SHAME
AFTER FAILING.
SO WHAT HAPPENED TO
ELIZABETH WARREN?
IS AN INTERESTING STORY,
ACTUALLY, FILLED WITH VALUABLE
LESSONS FOR POLITICAL CANDIDATES
AS WELL AS THE REST OF US.
BUT WARREN WAS IN NO MOOD FOR
LEARNING TODAY.
SHE ARTIE KNEW THE ANSWER, SHE
ALSO OFTEN DOES COME AT IT
TURNED OUT TO BE THE SAME ANSWER
SHE HAS IT OFFERED IN
RESPONSE TO VIRTUALLY EVERY
QUESTION SHE HAS BEEN ASKED OVER
THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
IT WAS SEXISM, THAT IS WHY SHE
LOST.
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS, THE MAJORITY
OF WHOM ARE FEMALE, HATE WOMEN,
WARREN EXPLAINED.
THEY MAY HAVE NOMINATED A WOMAN
IN THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL RACE,
BUT I WAS PROBABLY AN ACT OF
SEXISM.
THAT IS HOW SEXIST THEY ARE.
SUPER-DUPER SEXIST.
>> IF YOU SAY YEAH, THERE WAS
SEXISM IN THIS RACE, EVERYONE
SAYS.
AND IF YOU SAY NO, THERE WAS NO
SEXISM, ABOUT A BAZILLION WOMEN
SAY, WHAT PLANET DO YOU LIVE ON?
I PROMISE I WILL HAVE A LOT MORE
TO SAY ON THAT SUBJECT.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A PROMISE,
SHE SAID.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WILL BE
MANY MORE LECTURES ON SEXISM TO
COME FROM PROFESSOR WARREN.
BUY YOUR TICKETS NOW, THE WHOLE
IS CERTAIN TO BE PACKED.
IN THE FRONT ROW, YOU WILL SEE
YOUR FAVORITE CABLE NEWS
COMMENTATORS WHO ARE THEMSELVES
LIFELONG WARRIORS AGAINST
SEXISM.
YES, IT IS TRUE THESE ARE THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE SPENT
MONTHS NOW ACTING AS PUBLICIST
FOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AND NOW
JOE BIDEN, BOTH OF WHOM ARE
DEMONSTRABLY MALE.
BUT IN THEIR HEARTS, OUR FRIENDS
ON TV WERE ALWAYS ROOTING FOR
THE WOMAN.
THAT IS THE KIND OF PEOPLE THEY
ARE.
HIGHLY UNSEXIST PEOPLE.
>> OUR COUNTRY IS STILL VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WOMEN IN POWER.
MEN COME INTO A RACE WITH THE
EXPECTATION THEY ARE QUALIFIED,
WOMEN HAVE TO PROVE THEMSELVES.
A WOMAN TAKES A HIT,
PARTICULARLY A MALE CANDIDATE,
SHE TAKES A HIT IN HER
LIKABILITY.
>> SENATOR WARREN WAS HAMMERED
ON HER MEDICARE FOR ALL PLAN.
HER TAX PLAN, ANYWAY NONE OF THE
MEN WEARING THE ENTIRE LAST
YEAR.
TO ME, THAT WAS A SEXIST DOUBLE
STANDARD.
>> SHE WOULD HAVE DONE MUCH
BETTER IF SHE WERE A MAN.
I WOULD LIKE MORE MEN TO BE
VOCAL ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
WANT TO SEE WOMEN IN POSITIONS
OF LEADERSHIP.
>> Tucker: YAH, SEXISM.
YOU CAN SEE WHY ELIZABETH WARREN
IS SO UPSET TONIGHT.
TO BE FAIR, BERNIE SANDERS DID
WARN HER MORE THAN A YEAR AGO
THAT A WOMAN COULDN’T WIN.
HE DIDN’T WANT HER TO GET HURT.
BUT SHE JUST WOULDN’T LISTEN.
JUST KIDDING, THAT NEVER
HAPPENED.
WARREN MADE IT UP.
OR MAYBE SHE BELIEVED IT
HAPPENED, WHICH IS WORSE.
WARREN HAS CONVINCED HIMSELF OF
A LOT OF STRANGE THINGS
RECENTLY.
ITS BEEN POIGNANT TO WATCH IT
HAPPEN.
WARREN IS NO BETO O’ROURKE, SHE
ISN’T DOING PONG HITS ON HER
SKATEBOARD AFTER LUNCH.
SHE IS A LEGITIMATELY SMART
PERSON, WITHOUT QUESTION THE
SMARTEST CANDIDATE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD.
SHE IS ALSO TOUGH AS HELL, AND
FAKE INDIAN ASIDE
, SHE WROTE A BOOK ABOUT HOW THE
ENTRY OF WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE.
IT WAS INTERESTING, AND
WELL-RESEARCHED, AND ABOVE ALL,
IT WAS SERIOUS.
WARREN WROTE ABOUT A REAL
PROBLEM, ONE THAT AFFECTS MOST
AMERICANS, AND THEN THOUGHT
DEEPLY ABOUT HOW TO SOLVE IT.
THE BOOK WAS IMPRESSIVE.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN THE BASIS OF
A POPULIST PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
THAT WOULD’VE FORCED MUCH NEEDED
NATIONAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THESE ISSUES, AND IN THE END,
MIGHT HAVE WON.
BUT NONE OF THAT EVER HAPPENED.
WARREN GOT DERAILED.
MORE PRECISELY, SHE BECAME
INFECTED WITH A VIRULENT STRAIN
OF IDENTITY POLITICS.
BY THE END, LIKE TERTIARY
SYPHILIS, IT DROVE HER INSANE.
ONE DAY, WARREN WAS TALKING
ABOUT RAISING WAGES AND
PROTECTING AMERICAN WORKERS, AND
THE NEXT, RANTING ABOUT STRANGE
FORMS OF RACISM NO ONE HAD HEARD
OF AND ATTACKING THE COUNTRY SHE
ONCE SOUGHT TO IMPROVE.
ELIZABETH WARREN WENT
INTERSECTIONAL, AND IT KILLED
HER.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE FIRST
SYMPTOMS.
>> WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY NOW
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS ADVANCING
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM, ECONOMIC
RACISM, CRIMINAL JUSTICE RACISM,
HEALTH CARE RACISM.
>> Tucker: SO RAISE YOUR HAND
IF YOU’VE EVER HEARD OF
HEALTH CARE RACISM?
RAISED BOTH HANDS IF YOU THINK
IT IS ONE OF THIS COUNTRY’S TOP
500 PROBLEMS.
ELIZABETH WARREN THOUGHT IT WAS.
THEN SHE DECIDED IT WAS
IMPORTANT -- IN FACT, OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION -- TO INVITE THE REST
OF THE IMPOVERISHED WORLD TO
AMERICA TO SHARE OUR JOB MARKET
IN HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
HOW EXACTLY WOULD THAT HELP
AMERICAN WORKERS?
WARREN NO LONGER CARED.
SHE WAS TO WOKE TO WORRY ABOUT
ACTUAL PEOPLE.
SHE CLEARLY NEEDED IN PATIENT
CARE.
YOU WATCH HER SPEECH IS HOPING
MEN WITH NETSUITE SPRING FROM
THE SHADOWS TO CARRY HER OFF
TO A SECURE FACILITY TO GIVE HER
SOME REST.
IT SEEMED TO REACH ITS PEAK IN
JANUARY WHEN WARREN ASKED OUT OF
NOWHERE THAT SHE WOULD ASK
TRANSGENDER CHILDREN TO PICK HER
CAM THAT MEMBERS.
>> I’M GOING TO HAVE A SECRETARY
OF EDUCATION THAT A YOUNG TRANS
PERSON INTERVIEWS ON MY BEHALF,
AND ONLY IF THIS PERSON BELIEVES
THAT OUR SECRETARY OR SECRETARY
OF EDUCATION NOMINEE IS SOMEONE
WHO IS COMMITTED TO CREATING A
WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT, A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT, AND A FULL
EDUCATIONAL CURRICULUM FOR
EVERYONE, THAT PERSON BE
ADVANCED TO SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION.
>> Tucker: SO WHO IS THIS
YOUNG TRANS PERSON WHO GETS TO
STAFF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
NO ONE IN THE NEWS MEDIA EVEN
ASKED, BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT,
WARREN WASN’T THE ONLY ONE WHO
HAD GONE INSANE.
ALL OF THIS SEEMED PERFECTLY
NORMAL TO CNN.
BUT IT WASN’T NORMAL.
IT WAS SHOCKINGLY CRAZY, ALMOST
HILARIOUSLY CRAZY.
BUT WARREN WAS NOT AMUSED.
MOST OF THE TIME, SHE APPEARED
TO BE FLUIDLY ENRAGED, LIKE SHE
MIGHT LUNGE FORWARD AND FIGHT
SOMEONE.
FOR REASONS THAT WERE NEVER
REALLY CLEAR, WARREN REALLY
HATED BERNIE SANDERS, THE
ELDERLY EX-MAYOR FROM VERMONT,
THAT ONE POINT, WARREN CLAIMED
SANDERS WAS, IN FACT, A
DANGEROUS SEXIST.
BUT NOBODY BELIEVED HER, IT WAS
JUST TOO IMPOSSIBLE, WHATEVER
ELSE SHE IS.
SO SHE TURNED HER WRATH ON
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG, A FAR RICHER
TARGET.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
WHO WE ARE RUNNING AGAINST
COLEMAN A BILLIONAIRE WHO CALLS
WOMEN THAT BROAD’S AND HORSE
LESBIANS.
I KNOW, I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, I’M TALKING ABOUT
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING TO WIN
IF WE HAVE A NOMINEE WHO HAS A
HISTORY OF HIDING HIS TAX
RETURNS, OF HARASSING WOMEN, AND
SUPPORTING RACIST POLICIES.
DEMOCRATS TAKE A HUGE RISK IF WE
SUBSTITUTE ONE ARROGANT
BILLIONAIRE FOR ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: GOT TO GIVE HER
CREDIT, SHE CAN DELIVER A LINE.
BUT BY THIS STAGE IN THE
CAMPAIGN, NO ONE OUTSIDE CABLE
NEWS SETS AND COLLEGE CAMPUSES
WAS LISTENING.
ELIZABETH WARREN KEPT TALKING,
BUT NOBODY CARED.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT MOST
PEOPLE, EVEN DEMOCRATS, AREN’T
THAT INTERESTED IN
INTERSECTIONAL POLITICS.
THEY DON’T HOW TO PRONOUNCE THE
WORD MATIN LATINX.
IT’S STUPID AND WEIRD AND
FRIGHTENING.
IT HAS PRECISELY ZERO RELEVANCE
TO THEIR LIVES.
THEY WANT TO HEAR POLITICIANS
TALK ABOUT MAKING SCHOOLS BETTER
OR LOWERING HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS, THINK THEY ACTUALLY
THINK ABOUT IT HOME.
THEY DON’T WANT TO HEAR SOME
MIDDLE AGED LADY DRONE ON AN
EXTENDED GUILT TRIP.
BECAUSE IN THE END, IT IS REALLY
ALL ABOUT HER.
IDENTITY POLITICS IS ALWAYS JUST
A FORM OF NARCISSISM.
THAT IS NOT APPEALING TO
ANYBODY.
YOU CAN’T GET ELECTED DOING IT.